es wird deshalb chinas genannt die insel
hainan ist der südlichste punkt des
landes urlaubsparadies für die die es
sich leisten können
für die meisten die diesen sommer
hierher kommen ist es der erste urlaub
seit corona auch für phoenix sie
arbeitet in einem hightech unternehmen
und hat lange gezögert ob sie diesen
urlaub machen soll jetzt ist sie froh
hier zu sein auf ihrer to do liste
stehen erholung mehr und sport
doch ihr urlaub ende zu statt am strand
trainiert in einem kleinen quarantäne
zimmer in buch ausgerechnet wuchern wo
2009 10 die weltweit ersten corona
infektion entdeckt wurden
als wir ankamen und in dieser
einrichtung haben wir gelacht denn in
wuchern hat doch alles angefangen könnte
es noch dramatischer sein wir dachten
uns okay das ist ein guter guter stoff
für einen guten film
warum phoenix die aus georgien stammt
ausgerechnet hier landet das erzählt
dieser film es ist die odyssey von zwei
urlaubern wie sie zehntausende im august
in china erlebt haben
wie phoenix hat auch sega eine gute zeit
auf hainan endlich wie der urlaub
seit fast zweieinhalb jahren sind wir
nicht mehr rausgekommen wegen dieser
corona geschichte die grenzen sind dicht
mit seiner frau und seinen beiden
kindern war er auf rein an er hat eine
exportfirma und schickt uns diese
handyvideos um den geburtstag einer
freundin zu feiern mieten sie anbot
das war der hammer diese wieder
gewonnene freiheit
doch diese freiheit endet abrupt
plötzlich waren in unserer ferienanlage
so viele menschen ich habe direkt
gemerkt dass etwas nicht stimmt diese
leute wurden vom flughafen
zurückgeschickt weil alle flüge
gestrichen waren
denn am flughafen sieht es so aus
297 corona fälle so viele gibt es an
diesem tag laut offizieller statistik
auf der insel für chinas 0 kokot politik
genug um den flughafen dicht zu machen
ich muss meinen flug kriegen was soll
ich jetzt machen
es gibt keine flüge mehr die touristen
müssen zurück in die hotels keiner soll
das virus mit nach hause bringen
dann wurden wir in unserer anlage
eingesperrt wir mussten bleiben dürfte
nirgendwo hingehen
gefangen im paradies sieben tage soll
das so bleiben jeden tag ein pcr-test
die hotels sollen die preise um 50
prozent reduzieren
das hatten wir nicht eingeplant
du planst für einen bestimmten zeitraum
und plötzlich musst du so viel geld
ausgeben das so nicht eingeplant hast
cesar bleibt positiv er kommt aus
shanghai und hat den lockdown im
frühjahr mitgemacht er machte viel sport
als er seine wohnung zwei monate lang
nicht verlassen durfte inklusive
homeschooling mit den kindern
ich habe zu meinen freunden gesagt das
hier ist das upgrade zum lockt dorn in
shanghai jetzt haben wir die beste
aussicht meerblick und strand
dieser hat in diesem urlaub schwimmen
gelernt erzählt er uns stolz
doch jetzt werden die regeln in seinem
hotel immer strenger der pool ist
gesperrt kinderbetreuung abgesagt in
manchen hotels dürfen die gäste ihr
zimmer nicht mehr verlassen
cesar darf noch zum strand schwimmen ist
aber verboten
wir müssen nach hause
wir müssen nach hause als sie nach
sieben tagen immer noch fest hängen
organisieren einige familien eine demo
in der lobby
die chinesischen staatsmedien zeigen ein
ganz anderes bild glückliche touristen
auf dem heimweg die sich für die gute
organisation bedanken
sie haben uns sehr gut geschützt heute
können wir heim ich freue mich das ist
das bild das die medien transportieren
sollen ein staat der sich um sein volk
kümmert extreme maßnahmen bei jedem
einzelnen corona fall alles nur zum
wohle des volkes
videos von urlaubern die sich über die
häufig sinnlosen maßnahmen beschweren
oder zeigen wie der staat sie damit
gefangen hält werden zensiert
das nervt auch phoenix als sie nach zehn
tagen hotel gefangenschaft die insel
endlich verlassen kann darf sie nicht
zurück nach hause nach peking in der
hauptstadt gelten noch strengere regeln
deshalb muss sie sieben tage
zwischenstation machen in einer stadt in
der es gerade keinen einzigen corona
fall gibt sie nimmt den ersten flug den
sie kriegen kann ausgerechnet nach hahn
wir wussten nicht dass wir in ein
krankenhaus gebracht werden es ist
buchstäblich ein krankenhaus es gibt
nichts es gibt kein wlan
sie zeigt uns ihren raum auch die 15
negativen pcr tests die sie bis dahin
gemacht hat helfen ihr nicht weitere
sieben tage ist sie eingesperrt in
diesem zimmer
cesar hat mehr glück er fliegt mit
seiner familie nach shanghai nach drei
tagen hotel quarantäne dafür die
restlichen vier zu hause verbringen als
wir mit ihm sprechen hat er es fast
geschafft
ja um mitternacht da werde ich nicht
schlafen und mitternacht werde ich
rausgehen werde rumlaufen und freiheit
schreiben
noch nie hat phoenix so etwas in china
erlebt und sie lebt schon seit 17 jahren
hier sie macht sich sorgen um ihre
katzen zu hause nur so lange weg zu sein
das war nicht geplant
ich werde nicht mehr reisen bis sie
offiziell verkünden dass alles vorbei
ist denn was ich jetzt erlebt habe ist
einfach zu viel und ich weiß dass es
vielen menschen so geht es ist einfach
so du kannst den nächsten schritt nicht
vorhersagen weißt nicht was morgen
passiert wenn du dein haus verlässt
weißt du nicht wenn du zurückkommst
sie wollte eine woche urlaub machen nach
drei wochen darf sie endlich zurück nach
hause sie ist vor allem eins müde und
hat es satt dass die korona politik
chinas ihr leben bestimmt sobald sich
eine chance ergibt will sie das land
verlassen
[Musik]